y aller
la période
oui
je croyais
je
et
la côte de beauté
parra
m
qu'importe
bonsoir bienvenue à cette 30ème
commémoration du féminicide survenu le 6
décembre 1989
à la polytechnique de montréal a on va
recommencer alors bonsoir tout le monde
comme je disais bienvenue à cette 30ème
commémoration du féminicide survenu le 6
décembre 1989
à la polytechnique de montréal merci
d'être ici en si grand nombre ce soir je
m'appelle karine vanasse et je vous
accompagnerai tout au long de cette
cérémonie
tout d'abord son excellence la très
honorable julie payette gouverneur
général du canada s'adressera à vous par
la suite
madame catherine bergeron présidente du
comité mémoire vous souhaitera la
bienvenue
nous rendrons ensuite hommage aux 14
victimes de polytechnique par
l'illumination des faisceaux dans le
ciel de montréal
nous serons également en direct avec des
universités québécoises et canadiennes
qui commémore la tragédie de
polytechnique avec nous
après un moment de recueillement vous
entendrez les voies d'un coeur qui se
trouve derrière moi et en terminant des
fleurs seront déposées au pied de la
mosaïque en hommage aux 14 victimes
le premier ministre du canada monsieur
justin trudeau
le premier ministre du québec monsieur
françois legault et la mairesse de
montréal valérie plantes feront une
brève déclaration à la fin de cette
cérémonie se veut ni news go and clyde
river symphony orchestra
c'est ici même sur ce belvédère le 31
juillet 1940 que la violoniste virtuose
et l stark a mené le premier orchestre
symphonique féminin jamais créés au
canada
c'est donc symbolique de rendre hommage
aux femmes ici ce soir avant de céder la
parole à notre prochaine invitée
j'aimerais mentionner un ouvrage sur
polytechnique publié aujourd'hui même
ce jour là parce qu'elles étaient des
femmes écrit par l'auteur et journaliste
josée boileau
ce livre en hommage aux victimes en
racontant à rencontre en racontant
pardon leur histoire personnelle en plus
de dresser un portrait de l'histoire du
féminisme au québec
des exemplaires sont en vente à
l'intérieur et à l'extérieur du chalet
j'inviterais en maintenant son
excellence la très honorable julie
payette gouverneur général du canada à
vous dire quelques mots aux lightning
mike smith julie payette canada
bonsoir je suis je suis ingénieur je
suis une femme ingénieur et le 6
décembre 1989
j'ai étudié le génie comme mes collègues
hans interne au annie turcotte
anne marie lemay un mari adword barbara
daigneault geneviève bergeron allan
green maryse laganière arij leclerc maud
haviernick michèle richard
nathalie
sonia pelletier qui étudia le génie
nathalie croteau et barbara plus tonique
médaille évident qu'ils étudiaient les
soins infirmiers
j'étais à l'université comme elle par
choix simplement j'étais là pour n'ont
pas changé les statistiques ou défié les
normes pas par idéologie ni par
militantisme pourtant je suis féministe
j'étais là parce que j'aimais la
profession que je voulais en faire une
carrière
because se trouve quelque chose
la majorité des polytechnique leur vie
si horriblement écourtée et la vie des
94 autres blessées
merritt exige qu'une discussion
franchement du contexte plus large dans
lequel cette tragédie s'inscrit un
meurtrier
seul armé d'un fusil d'assaut mais
derrière ces actes se profile un tissu
de préjugés de sexisme qui enveloppe
encore aujourd'hui notre culture et ses
préjugés sont difficiles à changer
nous nous devons de le faire tous
ensemble
hommes et femmes à la violence verbale
et écrite que nous voyons si souvent
dans les médias dans les réseaux sociaux
que l'on entend on se doit de dire non
non
doublettes ligne de 10 yuans eisenheim
crawling daoui obscur sceaux afin
d'empêcher les to anyone who run the
edge of the crowd we have to speak up nc
nous
au respect des femmes partout autour de
nous dans nos familles dans la société
et au travail
nous devons l'exigé et à la violence
familiale
nous devons nous opposer pour que ces
magnifiques jeunes femmes ne soient pas
mortes en vain que jamais cela ne se
reproduise plus jamais chers membres des
familles distingués invités mesdames et
messieurs nous font l'honneur de leur
présence
son excellence la très honorable julie
payette gouverneur général du canada
correction ci devra être une embolie
payet grunge role of canada le très
honorable justin trudeau premier
ministre du canada et madame sophie
grégoire rightnow justin trudeau prime
minister of canada elles misent s'offrit
grégoire l'honorable michel doyon le
tenant gouverneur du québec et madame
pauline théberge d anovo michel doyon du
tengu vanhove cobac
nb si pauline théberge monsieur françois
legault premier ministre du québec et
madame isabelle aubret mais ce françois
legros le goût pur mais hors québec m me
isabelle aubret madame valérie plantes
mairesse de montréal et son fils émile
miss valérie plante mère ventures henson
emile monsieur philippe tanguy directeur
général de polytechnique montréal
messieurs philippe tanguy president
polytechnique
montreal madame catherine bergeron
présidente du comité mémoire miss
catherine bergeron president of the
committee mémoire
bonsoir et bienvenue à tous à cette
soirée commémorative du féminicide de
polytechnique
je m'appelle karine vanasse et je suis
particulièrement touchée d'être ici ce
soir
pour souligner la mémoire de 14 jeunes
femmes victimes du féminicide survenu le
6 décembre 1989 à 17h10 par un soir
grille est enneigée comme ce soir 14
femmes sont mortes
tout simplement parce qu'elles étaient
des femmes et qu'elle souhaitait
réaliser leurs rêves dans nos sociétés
quatorze vie envolée en seulement 19
minutes
quatorze autres personnes ont également
été blessées en plus en plus de
bouleverser de nombreux témoins et
d'ébranler toute une société
trente ans plus tard nous nous
recueillons pour elle afin de ne jamais
oublier l'erreur we are working est de
retour sur les greens ever never before
j'éviterai maintenant madame madame
catherine bergeron président du comité
mémoire et soeur d'une des victimes à
venir vous adresser la parole au
lightning mike smith catherine bergeron
president of the committee mémoire and
sisters avant 9,2 victims
tu sais few words
sherman des familles blessées survivants
survivante distingue les invités vous
tous amis citoyennes citoyens
bonsoir ce soir devant vous avec vous
j'ai l'âme à la tendresse le 6 décembre
1989 nous avons vécu une très grande
peine d'amour
la perte de 14 femmes extraordinaires
il y a trente ans elles se sont levés au
petit matin
confiante en l'avenir pas seulement le
leur mais aussi le nôtre
paris 18 mai respectivement which is
better y aurait-il un point remember la
mémoire permet de refaire le chemin en
sens inverse et de revenir au présent
avec quelque chose de plus apaisée au
coeur tenait un moment donné je me
souviens que les histoires de vie les
quatorze femmes ont façonné notre
histoire nous ne sommes pas elle mais
nous sommes assurément fait d'elle je me
souviens que nous n'accepterons plus
jamais que des femmes meurent parce
qu'elles sont des femmes
ceux-ci rich and just under the bridge
avant jazz dette
patrick entre en scène de rigueur
les quatorze faisceau qui s'allumeront
nous dise où nous sommes et surtout où
nous en sommes dix fortune beans or
light la race noire oui à annaba bord d
al qaïda tout est we want to be en 7 3
30e commémoration nous devons nous
promettre d'être les gardiennes
et les gardiens vigilants de la place
des femmes dans la société
we need to ensure that man and woman
voix et call in europe and alive np6
qu'amélie times forum à ses quatorze
femmes qui ont été à toutes celles et
ceux qui seront aux familles endeuillées
aux survivantes aux survivants aux
étudiantes et aux étudiants qui étaient
présents en 1989 aux intervenantes et
aux intervenants qui les ont aidés à
nous je souhaite tout la paix possible
irish os 10 6 ring pise les lumières qui
s'élèveront une à une
vous sont dédiés mesdames de lights the
chain of conan candidate d arlit riou in
humans and memory du fond du coeur
permettez nous de vous aimer toujours
[Applaudissements]
c'est qu'à part cela mettait dans la
jeune vingtaine elle était brillante
elle avait l'avenir devant elle
plusieurs d'entre vous ici ce soir
n'auront pas eu la chance de les
connaître ni de les rencontrer
j'éviterai donc blanche hommage aux
béland et sébastien chagnon tous deux
étudiants polytechnique à venir
prononcer le nom des 14 femmes dont la
vie a été abruptement interrompu
polytechnique blanche mahjoub élan et
sébastien chagnon willard lines of the
working woman week end
geneviève bergeron
hélène colgan
nathalie croteau barbara daigneault
anne marie edward maud haviernick
barbara maria clinique pitaya beach
maryse laganière marie leclerc
anne marie lemay sonia pelletier michel
richard annie st-arnaud annie surcote
ce soir nous sommes ici rassemblés pour
elle mais nous ne sommes pas seuls
il ya des milliers de personnes à
montréal au québec et au canada qui sont
avec nous fourtine women in canada en ce
moment même en plus polytechnique 14
universités québécoises et canadiennes
commémore le féminicide du 6 décembre
je vous invite à regarder les images en
direct de différentes cérémonies qui se
déroule à travers le canada qui hurlent
polytechnique ena fourtine l'université
de la colombie britannique à vancouver
l'university of british columbia et
vancouver
le collège militaire royal du canada à
kingston au canada inc kingston
l'université laval à québec université
laval inc big three
l'université dalhousie à halifax
dalhousie university halifax
merci à tous universitaires et gens du
pays pour votre solidarité
fettouhi nouri jouini en mémoire des 14
victimes
nous allons maintenant surveiller moment
de silence
[Musique]
oh
oui
quand
bon
on joue
[Musique]
oh
le
vous
on
[Musique]
oh
m
[Musique]
au
beaucoup
[Musique]
vous
non
[Musique]
et
où
à
e
[Applaudissements]
vous venez d'entendre le coeur éphémère
phoenix composé des membres de
l'ensemble vocal carpediem du coeur en
fugue de châteauguay et du coeur du
cégep de saint jérôme sous la direction
du chef frédéric voegel merci ça le fait
bien
[Applaudissements]
j'éviterai maintenant la mairesse de
montréal madame valérie présente ainsi
que ses invités à venir déposer des
roses blanches au pied de la musique
plus johnny and coming de meilleur
second rôle
mais si valérie plantes à zoug as tu as
des mosaïques
m
nous approchons maintenant à la fin de
cette cérémonie
j'aimerais que l'on promettent à ses
quatorze femmes que dorénavant
collectivement et individuellement nous
ferons de notre mieux pour nommer les
violences avec les mots qui les
définissent réellement sur promesse
forte qui nous amène we would be brave
et muse de write once again ce domaine
car oui nous avons le devoir de me
souvenir mais nous avons aussi le devoir
de reconnaître et de nomi
pour ma part c'est parce que j'avais
peur du mot féministe que j'ai voulu
mettre de l'avant le film polytechnique
il ya plus de dix ans aujourd'hui
seulement je trouve beau fort
rassembleur important et nécessaire
oui pour les femmes mais aussi pour les
hommes et pour les enfants
je veux ce soit profiter de cette
occasion pour mettre en lumière le
travail de ceux et celles qui se battent
et se mobilisent pour rappeler le droit
qu'ont les femmes et tous les êtres
humains d'exister pleinement et de
sentir en sécurité
alors pour vous éternel jeune femme pour
7 et 7 ans et les cet engagement que
nous faisons collectivement de ne jamais
vous oubliez à une battue aux chevreuils
the holmes de sky le vent symboliquement
les mains vers le ciel pour nous unir
aux faisceaux en guise de solidarité
d'espoir en un monde sans violence
d'unification et de puissance visible du
souvenir à vous tous merci
trente ans plus tard d'être ici pour
elle
merci à tous
[Applaudissements]
non
les yeux nous allons maintenant procéder
aux déclarations de la mairesse de
montréal du premier ministre du québec
et du premier ministre du canada
good evening with and gentlemen we made
you take me home entre deux premières
offres québec et au canada
bonsoir à toutes et à tous mes premières
pensées sont tout d'abord aux familles
des victimes aux amis qu'ils ont connu
ou survivantes et aux survivants et je
tiens à vous saluer vous tous et toutes
ici ce soir c'est c'est incroyablement
réconfortant et c'est bon de voir autant
de de mes concitoyens concitoyennes qui
sont réunis et je parle gaiement ya les
montréalaises et bien sûr on a des gens
qui ne viennent
plusieurs de nos collègues de la chambre
des communes et de la colline
parlementaire
merci d'être là mais de vous voir ici se
soient réunis pour honorer la mémoire de
celles qui ont été froidement abattus
parce qu'elles étaient des femmes et je
pense que pour celles et ceux qui nous
regardent en ce moment de vous voir de
nous voir comme ça tous et toutes
réunies ça montre la solidarité mais
cette volonté ferme de se souvenir oui
mais la volonté d'agir et on a tous une
responsabilité dans les petits gestes
quotidiens pour combattre le sexisme qui
justement fait trop partie du quotidien
et ensuite il y a les gestes que l'on
peut poser de façon plus plus forte ou
du moins plus globale et je pense bien
sûr vous avez ici même le premier du
canada le 1er mai du québec mairesse de
montréal et comment comment nous pouvons
agir également pour faire en sorte
d'avoir toujours une société plus juste
plus équitable et plus sécuritaire
et et si j'ai un message ce soir c'est
de conserver cette se souvenir de
prendre une photographie de vous tous et
tous réunis pour nous soutenir mais
également pour agir pour s'assurer que
plus jamais que plus jamais un geste
comme celui là un attentat contre des
femmes ne se reproduise plus jamais et
qu'en même temps nous n'oublions pas que
cette tragédie nous rappelle que bien
des communautés marginalisées dont les
femmes mais bien d'autres également sont
beaucoup plus sujet est sujette à la
violence la violence du quotidien les
des gestes aussi terrible que celui ci
alors je veux vous remercier
il remercie celles qui partout à travers
le pays ce soir sont avec nous merci
[Applaudissements]
justin valérie tous les distingués
invités et collègues sont ici merci tout
le monde est ici ce soir ça fait du bien
d'être ensemble y otra temps il faut se
dire les vraies choses il ya 30 ans 14
femmes sont fait voler leur avenir
parce qu'elles étaient des femmes il ya
30 ans 14 femmes qui avaient de
l'ambition qui était brillant sont fait
tuer parce qu'il y avait de l'ambition
pic était brillant ya trente ans le
québec qui a été attaqué dans une de ses
valeurs les plus fondamentales l'égalité
entre les hommes et les femmes
et ce soir tous ensemble
saint valery mois mais tous les
québécois
on a un devoir de mémoire
on a un devoir d'être unie pour jamais
baisser la garde
pour défendre cette valeur fondamentale
l'égalité entre les hommes et les femmes
merci bonne soirée
[Applaudissements]
il ya trente ans ce soir 14 femmes ont
été tuées par un homme parce qu'elle
était fin trente ans plus tard on a
encore beaucoup de travail à faire pour
lutter contre la misogynie de violence
fondée sur le sexe la haine et la
discrimination
oui mais stone age of today is everyday
de file aux every single you nba
nous allons continuer de combattre
ensemble la violence fondée sur le sexe
nous allons renforcer le contrôle des
armes à feu
éliminons ayant en interdisant
des armes d'assaut de style militaire
[Musique]
nous avons un consensus clair à la
chambre des communes
nous avons un consensus clair à travers
le pays oui oui fort
[Applaudissements]
là